- Our final presentation
will be by Claire Barnes.
Claire is a second year
masters of religion candidate
at Yale Divinity School,
concentrating in religion and ecology.
Claire has several fields of interest,
including food and
religion, climate justice,
indigenous representation in
International Climate Forums
and Gastronomical Archives.
She currently works at
the Beinecke Library
and worked at the Yale
Divinity Special Collections
this past summer,
about which I think we're
going to be hearing some more.
(chuckles) Claire also holds a masters
in international political theory
from the University of St. Andrews
and a bachelor's in
religion and philosophy
from Emory University, please
join me in welcoming Claire.
(audience clapping)
- Hi everyone.
So as Matthew said, my
name is Claire Barnes
and I study food and
religion at Yale Divinity,
particularly religion and ecology.
And I'm here to give, let's
see if I can get this to work,
duh duh duh
a general highlight from the collection.
I think as a student
worker in the collection,
I would love it if more people (giggles)
would visit the collection,
especially working within
smaller archival spaces,
it's quite rewarding for
both students and faculty.
And then I'm gonna be
focusing on some research
that I conducted with Chloe Star,
who teaches this class
called China Missions.
And so talking about the ways
in which students utilize
the collections in a classroom setting,
but also kind of untangling
some of the questions
and possibilities within
missionary archives.
And then further areas of study,
which are currently still being cataloged
in the Andover Newton
Collection, which has been added
to the Yale Divinity School's Collection.
So the history of the Yale
Divinity School Collections
is that there are 6,000 linear
feet of archival material
in our collections,
which ranges from pamphlets
to microform holdings.
We also have several areas of
specialization, for example,
which I will talk about later,
the China missions project,
which many of the China missionary papers,
and as well as Bibles and
translations of Bibles
are held in this project,
and they were acquired
in connection with the
China Records Project.
The Himalayan Mission Archive Collection,
and was formed in 2008
as an amalgamation of four
different archival organizations.
And it was transferred to
the Yale Divinity Collection
from the Center For The
Study of World Christianity
at the University of Edinburgh.
And then finally the Divinity
School also has a rich holding
of archives that have been transferred
from the Andover Newton
Theological School.
And these are still being cataloged
and there's room in this collection
for additional scholarship.
For example,
here is a papyri from the
Andover Newton collection.
The papyri collection
from the Andover Newton,
collection ranges from
1st to 6th century CE,
but this is from the early 4th century CE.
The collection also
contains personal papers,
archives of organizations,
pamphlets and papers,
and missionary postcards,
images, and ephemera.
We also have a really
interesting collection
of translated Bibles and also Bible folio.
So these are big Bibles
that would be used in a pulpit setting.
So the Bible on that, and
you're seeing right now
on the right is quite huge, quite large.
It's like this big, and these are on-site
and thinking about the ways in which,
how can we critically
analyze missionary culture?
We can think about the
intersection between linguistics
and visual culture within
these pieces for example,
a lot of these Bibles are
also illuminated manuscripts.
So you can see here,
there's an image of Genesis
that has been illustrated,
and thinking about the continuity
between our collections
in terms of visual culture,
there are also contemporary
forms of visual culture
that are quite interesting
in the collection.
These are two of my favorite pieces
from the collection
besides the work that I did
in Chloe Star's class.
So on the right, you can see here,
they're Chick Tracts and
Chick Tracts are comic,
little comic books that were
illustrated by Jack T. Chick
since the early 1960s.
And they document a fringe
evangelical responses
to upheavals in American culture.
And they're often placed in library
so students who will go
into libraries will see
these Chick Tract collections,
and they'll be inclined by their titles
such as global warming or
doom town to look at them,
but they actually are quite fundamental
are fundamentalist and
they're quite conservative.
But then on the other end of the spectrum,
we have these really interesting
pins from the collection
that also kind of, we can
think about the evolution
of religious visual culture in America,
particularly with these pins.
And these are from the Henry
Hale Butler Junior papers,
and these pins range from 1936 to 2013.
And as you can see, this
is one of my favorite pins,
"School of America, U.S.
Government Terrorist Training."
And it's not a cue for
people to think that,
"Oh, we're gonna have an
interesting conversation
"about global warming and
the evangelical papers."
And actually it'll be
something quite different.
But these are pins that
were collected by Butler
kind of in response to many things.
So for example, you can
see Jail Bush right there,
and there's conversations within
that we can have around these pins
in terms of both spiritual understandings
of American cultural shifts
and social movements,
but also in terms of kind
of a continuity thinking
about missionary culture
in America as well.
And then I think as a
student in the archives,
at least from a student perspective,
our archives are a great place
to think about
methodological uncertainties,
questions and possibilities
for missionary papers,
thinking about holding both
a criticism of the work
in our collection as
inter-tangled and colonial
and Imperial matrices.
And then also thinking about
what these pieces are saying
and what the missionaries are reporting on
in the places that they are.
So for example, if we can
think about geopolitical shifts
in the countries that
these missionaries are in
and what they're, how
they think about them,
how they think about their
friends and their families
in these countries.
And so holding both of those realities
and thinking Lamin Sanneh was a professor
of World Christianity at Yale Divinity.
And he in particular was interested
in looking at some of the linguistic work
that missionaries had done
and thinking about broadening
our use and understanding
of missionary papers,
thinking about them both critically
and thinking about their possibilities.
And the Yale in a book
group on World Christianity
in the History of Missions
continues his work
in this line of thinking
critically about our pieces,
not only in terms of their provenance,
but in terms of American imperialism
and also critical things
that we can gain from them
and in terms of social
and religious commentary,
and they meet every year and
they're also meeting in 2022.
So that will be if y'all are interested
in learning more about the
development of missionary studies
as a discipline, and also
rebranded as World Christianity,
thinking about disciplinary
boundaries within the archives
is quite interesting.
So now I'm gonna turn to my
specific research project
in China Missions, which
was with Chloe Star again,
who is an expert in
Chinese Christian theology
and has published an excellent
book on Chinese theologians.
But when I had entered her class,
which was an interesting hybrid class
between an exhibition style
of looking at both Jesuit,
like early Jesuit missionaries,
who were in China and as well
as translations of the Bible
in Chinese characters.
So that was kinda the
first part of the class.
And then the second part
of the class was dedicated
to individual research in the archives.
And so when I was thinking
about what I normally study,
which is religion and food
in an American context,
she had pointed me and Joan
and everyone in the archives
had helped me get to the Albert
and Celia Steward's Papers
and particular addendum
that had been brought
to Yale Divinity and had
not yet been processed.
So Albert Steward was
trained as a biologist,
but then served as a university professor
at the Christian College at
the University of Nanjing.
At that point it was spelled with a K
and you can trace the
evolution of the college
actually in its synthesis
with other universities,
from Republican era and
to the communist era.
But he taught at this university,
he taught botany and he
ran the herbarium there.
And he was there from 1921 to 1950
and was also like intern
during the Japanese invasion.
But I had focused my research
project on his papers,
and I was interested in
looking at the development
of what is called an
agricultural missionary
and thinking about these intersections
between agriculture,
religion, and national memory
and development in his collection as well,
there are a wide variety of things.
So he has like diaries, in the addendum,
which I processed actually,
he has ration cards from
when he was interned
and he has letters and whatnot.
And there are also lantern
slides and lantern slides
are small glass slides
that you put in a projector
and they're actually quite heavy.
So it's interesting
to think that they
would carry these around
to both document to their families.
Oh, like, this is where
I teach, for example,
this is a image of the campus,
or these are some of the challenges
that I'm facing in my work.
So in this right slide, we can see here,
it's labeled "Wasteful
cutting of forests."
But actually if we dive
deeper into his collection,
we can see that he is engaging
with different political
and policing bodies
during the KMT government
when this photograph is
actually documenting a moment
where this is a research forest,
and there were locals who
came and chop down the wood
for fuel because there
was resource shortages
during Japanese invasion.
And so he had to engage with
different policing bodies
within Nanjing at that time
to kind of balance his agricultural work
with the local conditions.
And it was quite
interesting about his work
is that he thinks about
what is often termed
by the university as the
Christianization of National Life
with these Christian colleges,
he thinks about his work in terms of land.
And so he has this interesting fusion
of thinking about his
religious experience,
and his experience teaching with his work
outside of the university,
because oftentimes both him
and his Chinese colleagues
would go out into the more local areas
and they would either gather plants
or they would work on local
conditions if there was droughts
or whatnot.
And we have a collection
thinking about my research
in terms of just his papers,
I think wasn't proving fruitful enough.
So then looking at other
pieces of the collection,
we have a repository of
agriculture and forestry notes,
which is at the college
that he was teaching at
within the university and
thinking the university itself
was positioning its work
in terms of a larger
agricultural policy for China.
And it would document
all of the professors
that had either been engaging
with agricultural policy talks
with the shifting geopolitical
lines and entities.
And then they were also very concerned
and he existed within this university
that was very concerned
about government recognition
of the university.
And so thinking about his
work in particular for me,
was quite useful that he
had joined a department
with nation building aspirations as well.
Okay.
And I think that he collected newspapers
from both American newspapers
and Chinese newspapers,
that document important
moments and diplomatic moments,
for example, this is at the
advent of during World War II.
And so thinking about
his role as a missionary
in this complex web of
his agricultural work,
and as well as the histories
and the developing histories
of not only China, but in
where he was a missionary,
but of the United States
and of political relations.
And I think what was really
important for our class
is teasing out our
understanding of missionary work
in different places.
And so in this example,
I was able to look at kind of
this complex web and matrices
of his life to think about
how we can push the boundaries
of missionary work in world
Christianity in general.
And also what has been
really quite rewarding for me
in terms of this work,
not only thinking about
like agricultural histories,
which I don't think we normally
connect with missionaries,
but which I think is quite
relevant in terms of colonization
and imperialization, both here and abroad,
but that the donor for his collection
was his son David Steward.
And he was able to engage
with my presentation
and add on points when I had
done my final presentation
for our class.
And so I think that in
a smaller archival space
that is in a larger library network
to think about the relational
aspects of our work
is quite important.
And we still email today and he adds
I think great insights
into some of the work
that I had been doing,
particularly around his
father's orientation,
towards his teaching and his work.
And also on his experience
as a kid growing up in China
at that point, and thinking
about also the family legacy,
and what as a student worker,
which I had transitioned
to after this project,
it made me think about,
in what ways can we
better archive our work?
And in what ways can we handle our work
so that it reflects not
only the complexities
of the donor's life but also
of his continued family legacy.
And his son had actually been a professor
and he was quite interested
in seeing the development of this work.
And so I think that is a
great opportunity for students
in particular to be involved
with the donors understanding
of their own work and their own donation.
Agricultural histories and
Chinese missionary work
are also very tied to medical histories.
And this is an example of
another paper that I worked on
in which these are the
Edward L. Bliss Papers
that I cataloged in addition
to the Steward Papers
and helped with the finding aid for,
and this is a really interesting case
because I had a lecture in
medicine reached out to me
and had asked, "Are there any
connections in these Papers
"between agriculture, and
medicine, and religion?"
And so this is another example
of kind of the interdisciplinary work
that we can do when we
tease out the material
in these Papers.
And this is Bliss with his
students and colleagues,
and then these are examples
of what is in his collection.
So from photographs, to letters,
to passports which we have.
So the Yale Divinity Special Collections
are not only a repository
for this rich collection
of Chinese material and missionary papers,
but they're also a repository
for the history of YDS.
And so the Women's Center
Material is the third collection
that I was able to work
on as a student worker.
And this collection was
actually quite large.
It was 30 boxes compared
to Stewards collection
was about seven boxes,
but Joan Bates Forsberg,
who was the founder of the Women's Center
was quite heavily involved
in creating a network
of female seminarians to
understand their role,
not only as students, but in response to,
as I've mentioned with the
Buttons and the Chick Tracts
in response to different
moments in American history.
So different waves of
feminism, for example,
and also during, there're lots of material
in this collection on women's responses
to the Vietnam War and further industrial,
like the Military Industrial
Complex that it's development.
And they were very focused
on not only curricular advancements
for using more inclusive
language in their curriculum,
but just creating an
all-inclusive voice for women,
which right now is defined by the Centers,
anyone who self identifies as a woman.
And the current YDS Women's
Center is still in existence.
And they publish a journal called "Voice,"
which is fitting for their mission,
and we continue to
collect copies of Voice.
And so this is another way
in which the YDS archive
can be a great resource for
students who are interested
in the development of
YDS as an institution.
And then these are
further areas for study.
These are both medieval
manuscripts from 1500s,
and these are in the
Andover Newton Collection.
This is illustrated biblical
texts from Ezekiel, I believe.
And then the image on the
right is a cabalistic text
that has a combination we
were looking at it yesterday
of Hebrew and other languages.
And so thinking about the role
of smaller archival spaces
and really diving and
giving access to students,
to these novel pieces
that most people haven't delved into yet.
And so people can...
students in particular,
working with professors that
have a broader understanding,
both linguistically and
materially of the collection
can have a quite personalized experience
in the YDS archives thinking
about there are many avenues
and rooms for discovery in the archive,
as I hope you've seen
through this collection
as well as my own research
and there's room for relational building
within the archive in this way.
And so here is my contact information.
And if you'd like to contact
me, that is my email,
Joan Duffy is a senior
archivist in Yale archives
who can help you piece through
any of your interests that
you have in the collection.
And then Suzanne Estelle-Holmer
is our main librarian
and she has developed
excellent research guides
for further interdisciplinary connections
between contemporary texts
in our archival material.
So thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
(indistinct)
- [Audience] Happy to start with one.
You mentioned cataloging
when you were talking
about the Bliss Papers.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Audience] And I think
it's really interesting
what you were saying
about donor engagement.
Have you thought about,
I mean, we're in a moment
right where we're thinking
about how we catalog
and how objects have been
cataloged historically.
Can you talk a little bit
about your work in cataloging?
And you're working with a lot of materials
that come into play with
current social movements
and other things and how you
sort of navigate that task.
- Yeah, so when I was
first... so my class project
on the Steward Papers was
almost a hybrid project
where I was able to delve
into agricultural histories
through his lens,
but also I learned how to
internally catalog materials
based off of Yale Divinity
standards and external standards.
But I think that, particularly for me
thinking about provenance is
a really interesting question
and thinking about for the
evolution of world Christianity
or missionary studies how
that might come into play.
And I think that as a young researcher,
I think having fresh eyes
on research collections
is really important because we
bring in these considerations
and these concerns to the archive space,
and then it becomes an
intergenerational task
of figuring out how do
we uphold the voices
and the narratives that are
in the papers themselves,
such as Albert Steward,
but also how do we interpret
them to make them meaningful
for our current context and
for our current critiques
and also the possibilities
of missionary work.
So I think hopefully that
answers your question.
- [Audience] Okay.
Very well, thank you very much.
- Okay, thank you (giggles).
(audience clapping)
(chiming music)